on arrête la regarder les cinq dernières
années puis on a constaté qu'on avait
perdu 10 000 hectares en termes de
territoire agricoles est-ce qu'on a
réellement perdu autant de terres
agricoles au Québec
oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
de 2016 à 2020 plus de 9500 hectares
disparus selon les données de la
Commission de protection du territoire
agricole c'est l'équivalent de 16000
terrains de football les terres en
question ont notamment été utilisés pour
construire des maisons des commerces et
des industries ce qui a contribué à
l'étalement urbain l'exploitation des
ressources la construction de route et
de systèmes de transport comme le réseau
express métropolitain a aussi gruger une
partie si on recule il y a une dizaine
d'années davantage de terres agricoles
étaient sacrifié tous les ans
en 2008 c'est plus de 5000 hectares qui
ont été retranchés depuis 2016 c'est
sous la barre des 2000 hectares le
rythme a donc ralenti si des terres sont
retirés de la zone agricole d'autres
sièges aussi tous les ans au final la
superficie protégée en légèrement
augmenté dans les dernières années mais
selon l'Union des producteurs agricoles
et des experts ces terres sont rarement
aussi bonne qualité que celle qui
disparaissent en ce moment plus de 6
millions 300 000 hectares de terres
agricoles sont protégés au Québec mais
le total comprend aussi des terres en
friches et des forêts privés en réalité
c'est environ la moitié de cette
superficie qui est cultivée
[Musique]